-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing great tonight.
Now let's get to the news.
President Biden today signed
the Puppies Assisting
Wounded Servicemembers
for Veterans Therapy Act
into law.
Democrats are calling it
a vital service,
and Republicans
are calling it tyranny.
President Biden
announced yesterday
that the U.S. will keep
its August 31st deadline
to withdraw from Afghanistan,
added Biden,
"Because that's been the plan
since the very beginning
of the week."
Two members of Congress
made an unauthorized trip
to Afghanistan yesterday and
stayed for less than 24 hours
before leaving on a flight
that was intended
to be used to evacuate people
from the country.
In their defense,
that's just how Priceline booked
their trip to Cincinnati.
White House press secretary
Jen Psaki yesterday
praised former President Trump
for urging his supporters
at a rally over the weekend
to get the coronavirus vaccine
and said
the Biden administration
"will take anyone
who has a big platform."
Except right now the biggest
problem is the biggest platform.
President Biden
reportedly received
a classified intelligence report
yesterday
that was inconclusive about
the origins of the coronavirus,
contradicting
your uncle's report
that AOC slept with a bat.
According to a new study,
antibodies from llamas
may prevent infections
from coronavirus.
And, of course, now you can't
find any llamas at Costco.
The "New York Post" this week
published a negative review
of the restaurant at
the new Margaritaville Resort
in Times Square.
You think Jimmy Buffett cares?
He's not even gonna see it.
He reads the leisure section,
and the rest of the paper
is just to shield his eyes
from the sun.
He doesn't even know
that resort opened yet.
"It's 2021 already?
Wow, that was a good nap."
A theme park in Japan recently
shut down a roller coaster
capable of reaching speeds
up to 112 miles per hour
after four riders
reported injuries.
Apparently what happened
was the roller coaster
reaches speeds
up to 112 miles per hour.
Online platform OnlyFans
announced today
that it will cancel plans
to ban sexually explicit content
from its site
following an outcry from users,
but after the outcry,
users pretty quickly relaxed,
and then they just fell asleep.
And finally...
Finally, Harvard Law School
this week
unveiled their
new redesigned logo.
It's a mom telling her friends
her son goes there.
And that, you guys,
was the monologue.
They kept the Latin.